My Invisalign has--
-I have taken out my Invisalign--
-I have taken out my Invisalign...
...and this is the album.
(both laugh)
["Bury A Friend" playing]
[Billie] Good morning!
This is my parent's bed,
and I sleep in here
because I'm scared of monsters.
Today is a day to celebrate.
[Billie] We made this album in a bedroom,
in our house that we grew up in,
so, it's really like, anything is possible.
[Billie’s Mom] I honestly don't know
how any artist of any age
is doing it without a parent.
(music ends)
-Is that million?
-Yeah.
Oh, my God.
♪ Step on the glass, staple your tongue, ahh ♪
♪ Bury a friend ♪
♪ I wanna end me ♪
Bad. Again.
♪ End me ♪
Nope.
♪ I wanna, I wanna ♪
♪ I wanna end me ♪
Boom.
Ooh.
♪ The debt I owe, gotta sell my soul ♪
♪ 'Cause I can't say no, no, I can't say no  ♪
It sounds pretty horrible.
I think it sounds kinda awesome.
It's pretty bad.
["When the Party is Over" playing]
[Billie’s Mom]
It is a horrible time to be a teenager.
♪ Quiet when I'm coming home ♪
Kids are depressed.
♪ And I'm on my own ♪
[Billie] I look into the crowd, and I see..
every single person in there
is going through something...
♪ I could lie, say I like it like that,
like it like that ♪
...and I have the same problems.
♪ I could lie, say I like it like that,
like it like that ♪
I was like, "Why don't I turn this into art
instead of just living with it?"
Hey, you guys need to be okay.
'Cause ya'll are the reason I'm okay. Okay?
♪ Let me let you go ♪
[Billie’s Dad] You have to have faith,
you have to do your best.
Live your best life.
'Cause... what else?
♪ I could lie, say I like it like that,
like it like that ♪
Billie Eilish: The World's a Little Blurry,
streaming exclusively on AppleTV+ February 26th.